we have to talk about Ted Cruz
the ultimate alpha male strong powerful
looking at him is like eating a handful
of wasabi you know it burns but other
people love to hate on Ted Cruz for no
reason
like a Memorial Day when Teddy went to
cheer on his Houston Rockets wearing a
shirt that could only be described as an
uncircumcised turtleneck yeah spot-on
and now people are blaming him just
because the Rockets missed a record 27
three-pointers in a row and lost no way
it's not like every time James Harden
shot a 3 he saw Ted Cruz vomited in his
own mouth and then threw the ball
blindly into the crowd see when you're
as disliked as Cruz it's hard to stay in
politics but trust Ted to figure it out
Ted Cruz campaign is taking some heat
for fundraising mailers that it has been
sending out to voters the envelopes are
marked summons enclosed open immediately
and they suggest that perhaps you're
supposed to be due in court the San
Antonio news express has criticized the
mailer saying that it's meant to look
like a legal threat Oh brilliant trick
the disappointment of jury duty is
cunningly replaced with a much deeper
disappointment that you opened a letter
from Ted Cruz here to help us get inside
Ted's head
it's citizen journalist and master
tactician Tim bolts
answer me this why is Ted Cruz doing
this he's ruthless Jordan and when
you're as much of an alpha male as Ted
Cruz and I are people naturally dislike
you they'll say you're being way too
aggressive or sir we've told you you're
not allowed back at the Sherwin Williams
location but if you're that disliked and
still want to be popular then you have
to resort to today's tactic Trojan
horsing Tim's tactics Trojan horse see
what Ted Cruz and I know is that you can
Trojan horse yourself into anyone's
heart using fear after all Jordan
friends are just enemies who you haven't
electronically stolen money from yet
okay I know that it was a mistake to
give you my paypal password you didn't I
just watch you relentlessly see this
fake summons letter isn't the first time
Ted Cruz his Trojan horse people into
tolerating him back in 2016 he did the
same thing in Iowa when he sent out a
mailer that looked like a legal
violation what's wrong with a little
friendly intimidation nothing legally
blink in fact that's why I send all my
party invites out as threats like this
invite I sent out for my 4th of July
party
it says notice to vacate and head over
to Tim's for some ice-cold brews
or the directions to my Super Bowl
shindig that said I have your kids and
some artichoke dip this strategy also
works great when someone else is
throwing a party at the same time as
yours just calling a bomb threat and
when they all come running out you're
standing there with a grill full of
birds and dogs for all your terrified
future friends so that was my niece's
christening and weren't you so relieved
once you realize the bomb wasn't real
but my rented bouncy castle was that's
Trojan horsing now Ted Cruz and I know
that life is all about getting people
out the door and into your clutches you
know do you find people are starting to
catch on to this tactic I mean Ted Cruz
has done this at least twice and people
hate them so much
a great point Jordan that's why you
always have to raise the stakes get
creative come up with a secret zodiac
code that you can mail out to the press
before you murder again like Ted Cruz
does or leave a horse head in their bed
that has an invite in its mouth to your
adult male Kinson Europe which reminds
me Jordan this is for you there's a
horse head in there isn't there the
answer is yes Jordan yep
by the way do you know of anyone that
needs a freshly murdered horse body I
invited 200 people to this party so I
have what you might call a lot of horse
torsos lying around 10 bolts everyone
the fight continues
[Music]